We are now ready to formally
define the Class P.
Most precisely, P is the set of
languages recognized by an order n to
the k deterministic Turing machine for
some natural number k.
There are several important things
to note about this definition.
First, is that P is a set of languages.
Intuitively, we talk about
P as a set of problems, but
to be rigorous, we have to ultimately
define it in terms of languages.
A second point is
the word deterministic.
We haven't seen a nondeterministic
Turing machine yet, but one is coming.
Deterministic just means that
given a current state and
tape symbol being read there's only one
transition for the machine to follow,
but in order n to the k time Turing
machine here I mean, a Turing machine
with running time order n to the k as
we defined the terms a minute ago.
Perhaps the most interesting thing about
this definition is the choice of for
any k in the natural numbers.
Why is this the right definition?
After all, if k is 100,
then deciding the language
isn't tractable in practice.
The answer is that,
the notion of the class P
doesn't exactly capture what
is tractable in practice.
It's not clear that any mathematical
definition would stand the test of
time in this regard,
given how often computers change.
Or how it could be relevant in so
many context.
This choice however does have
some very nice properties.
First, is that it matches tractability
better than one might think.
In practice k is usually low for
polynomial algorithms and
there are plenty of interesting
problems not known to be in P.
Second, is that the definition is
robust to changes in the model.
That is to say P is the same for
single tape, multitape machines,
random access machines, and so forth.
In fact, we pointed out
that the running times for
each of those models are polynomially
related when we introduced them.
Lastly, P has a nice property of closure
under the composition of algorithms.
If one algorithm calls another
algorithm as a subroutine a polynomial
number of times, and
that algorithm is still polynomial and
the problem it solves is in P.
In other words, if we do something
efficient a reasonably small number of
times then the overall
solution will be efficient.
P is exactly the smallest
class of problems
containing linear time algorithms and
which is closed under composition.